Wow! This is electric.
Let's kick it off!
-Welcome to the...
-...Rock and Roll...
Hall of Fame!
♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ROBERT DOWNEY JR.:
What makes for longevity,
consistent quality over time,
and plus, headbands.
Get on your feet
for Duran Duran!
We get to make people
feel better about themselves.
Thank you!
Pat was my hero
and immediate icon.
It has been an incredible ride.
Eminem is the best-selling
hip-hop artist.
EMINEM:
This is crazy. Thank you.
Their sweet dreams were forged
in the furnace of faith.
Music is in our souls.
We still rock.
When Lionel shows up,
everyone gets happy.
Rock and roll is not a color.
It's a vibe.
Carly Simon's range
and sophistication are peerless.
Judas Priest are
the definitive metal band.
ROB HALFORD:
Everybody's welcome.
That there is what
heavy metal is all about.
P!NK: Dolly Parton!
DOLLY PARTON:
I figure if I'm gonna be in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame...
I'm gonna have to earn it.
I'm a rock star now!
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Woo!
That's rock and roll!
Good night, everybody!